candidate for Venezuela's main
opposition Coalition has a message for
the country's
president Nicholas Maduro isn't going to
choose the people's
candidate but that seems to be exactly
what the president's done because Maria
Corina Machado who won October
opposition primary by a landslide has
been disqualified from the country's
2024 elections the decision was made by
a supreme court headed by a ruling party
loyalist but it could come at a cost for
Venezuela and candidates in October the
United States lifted some of its
sanctions against the country partly in
exchange for the government committing
to let some banned opposition figures
back into politics now the US says it's
reviewing its sanction policy again Mr
Maduro and his regime have decisions
they have to make we want to see them
meet the commitments they made back in
October to allow opposition parties and
candidates to run appropriately and to
release political prisoners we have
decisions to make as well if they don't
do that uh they've got till April we'll
see what they do meanwhile machad a
right-wing political veteran says she
won't step aside for a substitute
candidate we are going to beat Nicholas
Maduro in elections this year and we're
going to do it together it's not clear
who a substitute would be anyway some
opposition figures have been banned
others have fled the country along with
more than 7 million other
people it points towards another vote in
which president Nicholas Maduro comes
out on top his prize an 11th year in
charge of a country in a long-standing
humanitarian and economic crisis John
Holan aljazera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer